-Welcome back to the show.
You've been on our show
many times.
You've cooked for us.
We've done games.
Do you remember the one
where I was upside down?
-I still remember.
-Yeah, it's like I thought maybe
you could taste food differently
if you were upside down,
and it tastes the same, yeah.
I want to talk about this
because, obviously, a lot of
people are fans of you
and Eleven Madison Park,
and all these restaurants had
closed at the start
of the pandemic, and then you
reopened last summer.
And you just announced that
it's all plant-based.
You changed the --
I mean, you won awards.
You were the best restaurant
in the world.
Why would you take that risk
and what happened?
-You know, when I started
the career, I went at it
with an athlete's mentality, and
I wanted to work for the best.
I wanted to be the best.
I wanted to reach every accolade
that was out there.
And as you said, in 2017,
we became the best restaurant
in the world.
And shortly thereafter,
the pandemic hit,
and it was devastating
for our industry.
And it gave us time to sit back
and rethink everything.
And I was thinking about that
mountain top that I climbed
for so many years and how broken
so many of those systems were
and also how empty I felt
and that there is much more
to do than accolades.
During the pandemic, not knowing
if there was going to be
a future of Eleven Madison Park,
I turned the restaurant
into a community kitchen,
and we cooked over
a million meals
for food-insecure New Yorkers.
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's awesome. Amazing, buddy.
-And as good as that was,
of course,
it really filled my tank.
It was really satisfying, and I
reconnected with food in a way
I wasn't connected to
in a very long time.
And I realized that food
can make change
and that food is my language.
So when it was time to reopen
the restaurant, for me,
it was crystal clear that
the future was plant-based
and that the world didn't need
another preparation of
butter-poached lobster
or crispy skinned duck.
We needed to use our creativity
to make that future
more delicious, more beautiful,
more meaningful.
-So, you created
Eleven Madison Home --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I want to show everyone.
This is the box.
This is the box you get.
And right now it's
in New York City, right?
But if you go to
elevenmadisonhome.com,
you sign up for this, and then
what is your mission with this?
-You know, so many of our guests
now leaving the restaurant are
telling me, "Oh, if plant-based
could be like this,
I would eat plant-based
all the time."
And so the idea of this is --
and it's not a new idea --
but it is much more urgent
than it has been.
And so the mission is to eat
plant-based one day a week.
We can all make a change,
one day a week,
and it will make a huge change
on the planet.
-You were nice enough to give me
one of the first boxes.
Early on, I had COVID
and I didn't leave my house,
like you're supposed to do.
I was by myself.
I said, "hey, bud, if you have
any spare food, I'm here.
I'm by myself."
And you go, "well, I'm actually
doing this thing."
And you sent me this box and
it's the most beautiful thing.
I just want to show you what you
get when you get the box.
You open the box, and it is just
like this.
We didn't just do this for TV.
It looks -- This is beautiful.
Like that. And this is
a full day --
breakfast, lunch,
dinner, snacks --
of the most amazing food and
a nice, beautifully written --
You have a story about the food,
where it comes from, the farms,
how you can make it
if there are things to make.
Sometimes they're just stuff
you eat out of the jar.
-It's meant to be
really super simple.
It's meant to tell a story as
well, like the restaurant does.
-It's the freshest carrots.
-Oats and carrots.
We also have products in here
of other people that we love
who are doing great things
in the plant space.
-And when you buy this, also,
you give back as well, right?
-So, for us, it was clear that
after the pandemic,
I wanted to create
this circular ecosystem
at Eleven Madison Park.
Every diner makes five meals
for people
in need with every reservation.
And so it was clear that with
every business going forward,
that has to be built
into the business.
And so it is with this box
as well.
-Yeah, so you're giving back
I can't even tell you what
a risk, what a gamble this is,
but what a great thing
you're doing,
and you deserve all the props
in the world.
You're brilliant.
You're a genius.
-Not really, but appreciate it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I love having you on.
Daniel Humm. Chef Daniel Humm.
To sign up for
Eleven Madison Home,
go to elevenmadisonhome.com.